I can't speak for other parts of the
country but I think California is
notorious for voters who aren't really
politically active politically aware and
that has created a vacuum fored po well
when it comes to politics I would say
right and so that's created an
opportunity for some of the
more far-left activist Fringe Of The
Party to basically take control of
things uh and I'm talking about like the
individuals who think that it makes
sense to literally abolish prisons and
police which unbelievable and then they
turn around by the way when I critique
it or criticize it it's like no no but
we don't actually mean abolish no no you
mean abolish Nome has closed two state
prisons during coid he released
everybody tens of thousands of people
from these prisons okay now he lied and
told everyone that the people he
released were all nonviolent offenders
all nonviolent offenders they're not all
nonviolent offenders